hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve another problem from this
week's leak code contest
minimum interval to include each query
we're given a 2d integer array of
intervals each interval has a
left value and a right value which
basically determines the length
and positions of the interval so right
like the left point and the right point
and so the interval is connected by the
left and right points
and of course the size of the interval
is just defined as
the right value minus the left value
plus one right basically
you know the size of the interval if
this was one this was two basically if
this
if we had this interval one and two the
size of the interval is going to be
two even though that even though the
length of the interval is one the size
is two because it contains two values
one and two if this was three then this
would be an interval of length three
three minus one plus one is going to be
three
because it contains one it contains two
in the middle and then
three it contains three points so that's
basically
what the size is in this case if we had
just a an interval with
one point right like maybe the left and
right value are equal then the size of
this interval is going to be
one we're also given an integer array of
queries and the answer to the
jth query this is where things are going
to get a little bit complicated
the answer to each query is basically
the size of the interval the size of the
smallest interval such that q falls
into the interval so for example we
could have maybe
one interval like this and then maybe a
smaller interval
like this and let's say we had a query
such that the query you know
the query is over here this is the point
each query is just going to be a single
value a point so
as we can see this point falls into two
different intervals which one of the
intervals is smaller
it's this little one over here right so
basically we're going to return
the length of that smaller interval for
each query
since we're doing a result for every
single query that we have we're actually
returning an array output basically
for each query like this is our query
array we have two three four
five for each one of these we're gonna
have a corresponding output value which
is gonna tell us the size
of the smallest interval that this query
falls into
if it's possible that a query like
two for example might not fall into any
interval that's available to us in that
case we return a default value of
negative one
it's also possible we could have
multiple queries that are the exact same
right there's no restriction on that
we could have a two query and another
two query so what's going to be the
brute force way to solve this problem
can you answer
that well for each query we're looking
for the minimum interval right so the
brute force will be
for each query just scan through the
entire
interval list and then find which one of
the queries
which one of the intervals the query
falls into that happens to be the
smallest interval right so two in this
case
which one of these four intervals is the
smallest interval that two falls into
it falls into this one and the length of
that is three it also falls into this
one
and the length of this one well actually
the length of this one is four the
length of this one
is three and it does not fall into this
one
and two also does not fall into this one
so what's the size of the smallest query
it's going to be 3
that's why we can see over here the
first value in our output is 3.
so what's going to be the time
complexity of that well it's just going
to be a nested for loop right we're
going to have
a length of queries and the length of
intervals right so multiply those
together let's say it's
you know n is the size of queries or n
is the size of intervals q is the size
of queries we're going to get n
times q is going to be the overall time
complexity
now is it possible to solve this problem
more efficiently
yes but not by much and i'm going to
show you what the time complexity is and
then i'm going to show you how to
actually achieve that time complexity
so it's going to be n log n plus
q log q because
the and and mainly this time complexity
is going to come
from the fact that we're going to be
sorting our intervals and we're going to
be
sorting our queries and once we do that
we can scan
our queries from left to right and
that'll and since our intervals are also
sorted
each query will be close to the interval
that it belongs to right the smallest
interval that it belongs to
so it'll actually end up being
relatively efficient once we sort both
of them but we're also going to actually
need a data structure
in order to actually find the minimum
the smallest interval
so we're going to be needing a min heap
to achieve
that for us so this problem is a hard
problem for a reason
it does have a little bit of difficulty
it's not super intuitive
but the solution is doable the code is
going to be about 15 to 20 lines of code
so pretty much like every interval
problem we're going to use the fact that
we can sort the intervals
to our advantage and just by looking at
the picture this is why i like to draw
pictures because it becomes more
intuitive
it wouldn't really make sense for us to
go brute force right
just like let's say the order we were
given these values was maybe
three and then four and then two it
doesn't make sense for us to do these in
a random order of course we would want
to do it from
left to right because the queries are
going to be close
to the intervals that they belong to and
we're going to get the smallest interval
that it belongs to and of course you
know for a query like this we're not
going to be necessarily looking at
intervals all the way over here
right that's 1 and of course we know we
could also have
multiple queries we have a query here we
could have multiple queries with the
same value and of course
both of them would have the same
smallest
interval that they belong to so you know
we could kind of cut down on the
repeated work like that
but so how is this going to work like i
said we're going to need a min heap
so we're going to iterate through every
single query right
ultimately we're trying to build our
resulting output
with the size of the minimum interval
that each query belongs to so
let's start with this query right it's
at the
its value is two so what are we gonna do
we're gonna start
iterating through our intervals from
left to right
you know since we've sorted them we're
gonna sort them based on the left value
of each
interval so in what order are we going
to iterate through these intervals
well this one has the smallest left
value this one is next
this one is next and then this last one
which is just a single point but it
still counts as an interval
is going to be the last one so starting
here what are we going to determine
what we want to do for this query is we
want to
add all possible intervals that this
query could belong to right
how do we know which intervals this
query could possibly belong to
well let's say we had an interval over
here right like something like this
since this interval is too far to the
right
of course this query is not going to
belong to that interval
how do we know that the what algorithm
or what kind of condition can we use to
check that well
take a look at its left value or its
start value of the interval
if the left value of this interval is
greater
than the point or this query right if
the left value is greater than the query
of course this query could not belong to
this interval
so the condition we're going to use
we're going to keep iterating through
these intervals
while the left value of the interval is
less than or equal
to the query so for example this is the
first query we're going to look at the
the left value is less than or equal to
this so we're going to go ahead and add
that query or add that interval
to our min heap how are we going to add
it to our min heap though remember we
want to pop the minimum
size so we're actually going to take
this interval and calculate the size of
it
how are we going to do that well 4 minus
plus 1 is going to be equal to 4. so
we're going to add
4 to our min heap but actually we're
going to add a
second value 2 because there could be a
condition where two intervals are the
same
length right we could have an interval
like this
right from here to here we could also
have an interval like
this from here to here both of these are
size
both of these are size 2 intervals but
which one of these intervals would we
want to
pop first of course we would want to pop
this interval first because it's farther
to the left right we'd rather pop
the leftmo most interval because
what if what if we pop this one first
from our min heap
but it turns out that there's a query
over here that actually
you know this is the answer for this
query we'd rather pop
this one because we're going to be going
from left to right
so we'd rather have this interval
belong to this query and we'd rather pop
this query
rather than popping this query first so
we're going to need
one thing to to be our tie breaker we
need a tie breaker
between these two intervals what's the
tie breaker going to be
it's going to be the right value of the
interval
we'd rather pop this one before popping
this one so we're popping the one with
the smaller right value so we're gonna
we're gonna have our right value as the
second key
of our min heap so we're gonna have a
pair for our key of the min heap
the first is going to be the size of the
interval the second is going to be the
right value
of the interval so in this case this is
the left value of the interval this is
the right value it's a value
of 4 so the what we're adding to the min
heap is 4 4 the first value is the size
the second value is the right value of
the interval
so we've added this to our min heap now
let's go to the next interval
it's this one right so so the left value
of this interval is technically less
than or equal to this it's equal to it
so
technically we are going to be iterating
through this one as well so what's the
size of this interval well
four minus two plus one so the size is
actually
three that's that's pretty good for us
right so we're going to add that to our
min heap the reason it's good is because
we found a
smaller interval that this value belongs
to right that
that necessarily didn't have to be the
case right it could have been possible
that even though this interval started
here it could have just been a really
long interval right
that's the reason why we're adding for
this query we're having to add
all possible intervals that this query
belongs to because we don't know what's
the shortest gonna be
that's why we need our min heap to
efficiently in log
n time to help us determine what that
smallest interval is going to be
so we got the size of that interval
what's the right value of the interval
take a look it's four so it's four in
this case well technically we don't need
that tie breaker because this is this
one is going to be popped first from our
min heat because it has the smaller size
but in case we did need that tie breaker
we do have it so now we've added this
interval to our min heap as well now
let's take a look at the
next interval hey take a look though
this interval
the left value is not less than or equal
to our query so we're actually
not going to iterate through this one
just yet we're not going to
be it we're not going to be adding it to
our min heap just yet
take a look at our output array now we
need an answer
for this query what is the size of the
smallest
interval that it belongs to well let's
take a look at our min heap
what's this what's the size of the
smallest interval
in it well we have two choices right
this one or this one
obviously this one has a size of three
whereas this one has a size of four so
this is the smallest one so we get a
three right three
is the size of the smallest query that
this
that this query belongs to right so what
we're gonna do is to our output
for the first value we're gonna add a
three oh and by the way
remember how we sorted these queries i
know i'm probably getting a little too
in-depth but that's just kind of the
nature of this problem there's just a
lot of like
bookkeeping and details that you have to
worry about remember how we sorted our
queries so technically we don't actually
know that this
is the first query we don't know that
this query
is going to be the one that corresponds
to the first position
in our output right so we're going to be
needing to do some
like bookkeeping to do that and all
that's what i'm going to show you in the
code because i don't want to get this
too complicated
basically we're going to be using a hash
map to make sure that we can
maintain the correct order of them but
okay so for this query right we're
basically done with this query now right
we don't have to look at it but
notice how i didn't actually pop this
from our min heap
why didn't i pop it because it's
technically possible that the next query
could also belong to this interval
right and this interval could could be
the smallest
interval that this query belongs to so
we're not going to be necessarily
popping the uh from the min heap just
because we found a result
okay so now it's time finally to get to
the next query this is going to take a
while i can tell
but so now we already added these two to
our min heap what about
this one right so let's take a look at
this left value is it less than or equal
to this query yes it is so we're going
to go ahead and add it to our min heap
first of all what's the size of this
interval well take a look
6 minus 3 plus 1 what's that going to be
that's going to be
4 so let's add 4 to
our min heap now what's the right value
going to be of the min heap
the interval the right value is six so
that's going to be the second value that
we add
to our min heap okay so we don't have to
worry about this interval anymore we
already added it to our min heap
now let's go to the next and actually
the last
interval in our intervals this one the
left
the left value of this interval is not
less than or equal to this so we're not
going to be considering this interval
just
yet so now it's time for this query to
determine
what is the smallest value what's the
smallest length
of the interval that it belongs to well
once again we're going to take a look at
our min heap we're going to get the
interval
that's the smallest interval from here
and we can actually do that in o of one
time because we're not actually popping
from the min heap but we will be popping
later
on and i'll show you why we do need to
pop from the min heap
later on but for now what's the smallest
value in the min heap
it's this one again right and that does
make
sense because take a look at this query
it does belong to this interval and this
interval is the smallest interval that
it belongs to
so for the size of the smallest interval
of this query we're going to add
3 once again and now we are done with
this query time to move on to the next
one
so remember there's only one query left
we already finished
this one so let's take a look at the
left value of this query it's a single
point query
so the left value is equal to the right
value is the left value
less than or equal to the query yes it
is so we're going to take this interval
and add it to our min heap what's the
size of this interval well it's going to
be 4 minus 4
plus 1 that's going to be 1 and what's
the right value of the
of the interval well it's going to be
one or it's going to be
four because it's a single point
interval
that's where it's going to go so now
we've actually added all the intervals
to our query so the next time we go to
the next query we want
we won't actually have to add more
intervals to our min heap that's pretty
good but
now it's time to determine for this
query what's the smallest interval
that it belongs to well let's again take
a look at the min heap
take a look at the smallest value now
that we added
the size of the smallest interval is now
one so
one is going to be the size that we add
to our
output so now we are done with this
query we only have one last query
left to consider so the good thing is we
added all the intervals to the min heap
so we don't have to do that
but now notice one thing
so now if we if we're trying to look for
the smallest interval that this belongs
to if we just
immediately go to our min heap and pop
and get the smallest one it's going to
be this one right
it's going to be 1 4. so then we're
going to end up adding a 1 over here but
is that correct let's take a look at the
picture
does this query belong
to the interval of size 1 it doesn't
like
look at this right if you go vertically
there's only one
interval that this query belongs to so
now
we're going to get to the the other part
of this algorithm that i didn't show you
yet
every time we're getting the smallest
interval that a query belongs to
first we have to make sure we remove
all invalid queries from
or rather remove all invalid intervals
from the query before we get the
smallest one for a query
and take a look at this interval right
so basically what we're going to do
is for this min heap we're going to get
the size we're going to get the smallest
interval
from that min heap right it turns out
that this is the smallest one as of now
let's take a look at that interval
well the right value of this interval
and
by the way remember we added the right
value to the min heap there's a reason
why we did it this is one of those
reasons we added the right value to the
min heap it's four
right four is less than five right
that means for example for five we we
might have like an interval like this
where the interval starts and ends
before we even
get to this query right so of course
we're not going to be considering this
interval so now we're at the part of the
algorithm we're going to loop
for every we're going to keep getting
the smallest interval and
while the right value of that interval
is less than the query
we're going to be removing that interval
from our min heap so right now we're
going to be removing this interval right
so now once again let's find the
smallest interval in our min heap
it's this one right because the size is
3. now let's take a look at the right
value of that interval once again it's
4. 4 is less than 5 so 5 does not belong
to this interval we're going to
have to pop from this interval and that
makes sense right because this
interval is size 3 this is the picture
of that interval right
or rather this is the picture of that
interval and of course
five does not belong to it so we're
gonna have to remove this
once again let's get the smallest from
our min heap
well these two are both size four so
which one are we gonna pop first
remember we had that
tie breaker we had a four and we have a
six which one are we gonna pop first of
course the smaller one
which is this one four four so let's pop
it we see the right value
is still less than five right so we're
gonna be removing this from our min heap
right so when you take a look at the
picture at this point we've removed this
from our min heap we've removed this
from our min heap
and this one the only left is this
interval and when we actually take a
look at that interval 4
6 we see the right value of that
interval is 6 size is 4 but the
the right value is 6 and that's greater
than
5 right so it's greater than or equal to
5. so of course
we're going to be this inner this query
does belong to that interval
so this is going to be the answer for
this query this query
the smallest interval that it belongs to
is of size
4 and this this happens to be that
specific interval so that's what we're
going to be ending up
adding to our output for this query
so this really isn't that easy of a
problem once you can write the code the
code isn't too bad but actually figuring
out
that you can you know do all this stuff
there's some pretty
neat edge cases that you have to worry
about you really have to get those
conditions right
greater than or equal less than or equal
right you really have to make sure
that your off by one errors are correct
so that was a pretty long explanation
but i hope that it does provide a little
bit of insight i would kind of
walk yourself through a couple more
examples if you need to
and as well as study some of the code
that i'm about to show you right now
so like i said we're going to be sorting
our intervals and we're going to be
sorting
our queries but i'm going to be
uh remember we do need the original
relative order of the query so i'm not
actually going to be modifying the
queries itself i'm just going to be
modifying it for this loop so when i do
this in python it's not actually
updating the original array queries it's
just that it's creating a copy of
queries sorting it and then we're
iterating through it
like this so there's that but also
remember that we are going to be needing
a
min heap as i mentioned and in python a
min heap is just an array but we are
going to have a
min heap class that is going to help us
i'm also going to have a resulting
uh data structure and an index i i
is basically going to tell us the
position that we're at in our intervals
array
but result is actually not going to be
an array it's initially going to be
a hash map and then we're going to
convert it into an array later on
and i is going to be initially set to
the beginning of intervals of course
that's the index
0. and the way we're going to do this is
for every query we're going to map it to
its smallest
the length of the smallest interval that
it belongs to and then we're going to
later on convert that into an array
maintaining the original relative order
of
queries so now we're going to start
iterating through
the intervals and of course we have to
make sure that our index is
inbound so i'm going to make sure that i
is less than the length of interval so
that's 1
and the second thing is we're going to
keep adding intervals
to our min heap while the left value of
that interval
is less than or equal to the query value
that we're currently iterating through
right we're only adding intervals that
the
that this query could possibly belong to
so we can get the left value of the
query
by getting first of all getting the
interval at position i and the left
value is going to be the first value at
index 0
we're making sure that it's less than or
equal to the query value that we're
currently
at if that's the case we're going to get
the left and right value from that
interval and of course we're going to
push it
onto our heap so we can do heap q dot
heat push
to our min heap remember we're adding a
pair of values we're getting the size of
the interval right minus left plus one
and the second value is going to be r
the just the right value for our tie
breaker
and of course since we just iterated
through an interval we have to make sure
we increment our i
plus one and so basically this loop is
just going to keep adding intervals
until either we run out of intervals or
the interval is
too far to the right for this query to
even belong to
and then once we've done that we're
gonna go on to our second part of the
algorithm
now is the part where we're going to
continue to pop from our min heap
we want to remove all intervals that
this query
doesn't even belong to how do we know if
there's an interval that this query
doesn't belong to it would only be the
case
if this interval was too far to the left
how do we know if it's too far to the
left
basically if the right value of that
interval
is 2 is less than the query value
q so first we're we're going to be doing
this from our min heap so we want to
make sure our min heap is non-empty
and for the the smallest value of our
min heap we can get that at index
0 in python so now we
at index zero we've gotten the smallest
interval and we want to make sure
that it's right value which we can get
at index
one and if this right value happens to
be
too far to the left meaning it's less
than the query value
then we have to pop from our min heap so
we're going to do heap q
dot heap pop from the min heap so all
this is doing
is popping all the invalid intervals
from our min heap popping the intervals
that are too far to the left
so once this loop has been done
executing either
then we're able to get from our min heap
get the smallest
uh interval which is going to be at
index 0 and then we want the size of
that interval so we can get
index 0 get the size of that interval
and that's
only if our min heap is non-empty right
it's possible that
for one of these queries that there's
not a single interval that it belongs to
in which case else is where we would
want the negative one which is the
default value that they told us
and for this we're going to be assigning
it to
result of that query so in our hashmap
result
of that query we're you know getting
this i know this is kind of a lot
even though that this is not a lot of
code these are a lot of details we're
having to worry about it's really easy
to go wrong in this problem it's not an
easy problem
but that is actually it right remember
if you remember the visual explanation
these are the main things we had to
worry about we're going through every
query adding all possible intervals then
popping the invalid
intervals and then getting the the
smallest interval that's left
in our min heap once that's done and
once we've done that for every single
query
we are done and so then we can return
our
result but happens to be that our result
is actually a hash map because we
remember we have to
we have to return the result such that
it matches the original order of the
queries
so how can we do that well for every
single query
in our queries array what are we going
to do for every single query we just
want the length the smallest length that
this query the length of the smallest
interval that the query belongs to we
can get that with result
of q for every query in our queries
and with python at least you can do list
comprehension
so we can create a list like this on the
fly but
you know this isn't really the difficult
part of this algorithm you could do this
with a few extra lines of code in other
languages if you needed to
okay but that is the entire code it
won't be super different if you're
doing like java or something it's
probably just going to be a different
min heap library as well as probably
this line is going to be different but
for the most part
you're going to be needing a hash map
probably and you're going to be needing
a min heap you're going to need to sort
these
input arrays and remember the time
complexity is just going to be big o
and log n where n is the length of the
intervals
and q log q where q is the length of
queries because the main time complexity
is coming from the fact that we're
sorting both of the inputs
but other than that i hope that this was
helpful for you this is not an easy
problem
i hope that you did gain some
understanding if this was helpful please
like and subscribe it supports the
channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching